and finally new rule in the next debate
when Donald Trump starts going on about
how everything in this country is a
total disaster Hillary must lean into
the mic and say wrong now god only thing
that Donald Trump's campaign by quiet no
not great we're into the end now Donald
Trump's campaign is built of course on
many fallacies but the one we really
need to debunk is that America is in
such a desperate place that a wild card
like Trump is worth the risk
Trump fans talk like they live in a
western town where the Bandidos are so
out of control only a maverick
gunslinger can save them man with no tax
code the fastest weed in the West it
covered in man's hand
not really worth that wasn't so a place
I don't need your pity wait wait I may
need your bit yeah yeah but I give
Donald Trump supporters a little credit
they know he's an [ __ ] it is hard to
hide they just don't care they'll admit
yes he's dangerous and thin skins and
unhinged and clinically insane and an
egomaniac a compulsive liar a charlatan
but the impulse control of a grease fire
but we have to take the risk because
America is hanging by a thread how do we
know it is Donald Trump told me the
situation is worse than it has ever been
before the generals have been reduced to
rubble our country is going to hell
our infrastructure is going to hell
african-americans Hispanics are living
in hell you walk down the street you get
shot the American Dream is dead
it's a sane I mean one of the popular
memes on the right these days I'm not
kidding is that this election is they're
calling it the flight 93 election as in
the plane on 9/11 that crashed in
Pennsylvania after the passengers rushed
the cockpit in other words things have
gotten so bad it's time to rush
America's cockpit as the creator of the
metaphor put it you may not make it into
the cockpit but if you don't try death
is certain
really president Hillary equals certain
death
what do they think she's gonna do poor
lead in the water supply
hood oh wait that was the Republicans in
Michigan
so there's that view and then there's
the fax remember them so old-school
aren't they but they tell us the country
is actually in pretty good shape
violent crime at its lowest since 1970
the military better funded than ever
Trump says our health care is a horror
show but more Americans have insurance
than ever fewer are smoking cancer is
down teen pregnancy is down alcohol
abuse is down somehow Dick Cheney is
still alive
[Applause]
Oh
[Applause]
eight years ago we were losing 800,000
jobs a month now we've added 14 million
the stock market went from under 7,000
to over 18 consumer sentiment is as high
as it was in the 80s under Saint Reagan
the economy today is actually better
than the one Mitt Romney promised in
2012 when he said he would get
unemployment under six Trump says you
have great economists that will tell you
the unemployment rate is thirty thirty
to know that every economist knows it's
five because they get their numbers from
the Bureau of Labor Statistics not from
the Department of um hearing
[Applause]
if Mitt Romney were running on this
economy the people with the make America
great hats would have reelect Romney
stickers on their rascal scooters but
the president isn't a white man with an
r next to his name so it's flight 93 you
know I've read so much crap about how
Trump voters are hurting and we should
respect their anger and their pain it's
a myth the media swallowed whole the
average Trump primary voter makes 72,000
a year no more likely to be hurt by
immigration or trade or to be out of
work Donald Trump doesn't really have
solutions and his supporters don't
really have problems
the only thing poor about them is their
judgment
[Music]
they're hysterics and they think
president Tupac spent eight years spent
eight years turning the American dream
into nightmare on black street and
Hillary's and Hillary's going to finish
the job the reason why Trump is so
popular with a certain type of voter is
because they're kindred spirits these
white men sitting at the end of the bar
nursing a gin and tonic because their
dick doesn't work anymore and life
didn't pan out the way they wanted so
they sit there crabbing about how the
system's rigged against them in America
is not winning anymore and we're getting
pushed around for everybody China and
Mexico and women and blacks who have so
many advantages over white people at the
convention Trump said I am your voice
for once he wasn't lying
he is your voice because you're a whiny
little [ __ ]
[Applause]